whatever wants to know is particularly
the Oscar fans who I think you love them
as much as they love you I mean you've
talked about our Stella ho they are your
friends and your family and you have a
real connection with that Club it is for
me yeah and I think the fans would love
if you came back and managed is that on
the cards at all oh don't look surprised
no don't even try you're sitting next to
an actor don't you know so much respect
for saying so if it does happen
eventually one day he's gonna have to be
after him because he has done such a
good job and have a big respect for him
so that's why sometime when people
mention manager I don't actually want to
talk about it right now because also in
is doing a great job and I respect the
guy so hopefully maybe after him yeah
but let's go from the other side then so
you love also the fans love you it's all
going great why did you leave why did
you go thankfully thank you for well it
seemed odd do you know reading about go
oh I love it I love a little bit bye
that's it that's the point
no it's just I said it when I left at a
time I wanted to be in the competitive
team and I for a time the weather the
weather Club was going wasn't the wasn't
the way I was seen it and I cried when I
left it was pretty it was pretty hard I
did I did
it wasn't an easy thing to do living off
small form is the United Nations I love
football so much I need to us take this
opportunity when you left me I felt the
team wasn't going the way you wanted to
go which particular signings did you
think weren't good enough
well you know what there must have been
some silence I see so you learn to say
is this what you like about living in
New York not mainly for me because
Austin is kind of a mentor for me father
figures and not knowing if he was I
wasn't going to sign for me was
difficult to know if I was going to stay
or not that's mainly for me the main
point of why I left
good answer but which of the signings
didn't you think he's not very bad to
her okay so here's the thing using
bender to Gascon I'm just wondering if
it was bad they might not maybe it could
have been anyone good enough to take it
to the champion I mean it could be
anyone could be anyone could've been
just one don't just ignore him pretend
it's not happening
counselor this is very surreal and then
the Queen came in and she said can we
join you and I said say no off
right beautiful gorgeous annoying you